highlight ist wieder eure mal wanne und
willkommen zu einer ganz speziellen
folge von wanne will's wissen
kg zwar geld auf dem grenzweg zu
schmeißen
frankreich hat mit seinem neuen gesetz
dass supermärkte keine lebensmittel
wegschmeißen dürfen
eine welle der begeisterung ausgelöst
und ich bin voll dankbar dass die diesen
schritt gewagt haben weil ich habe das
gefühl das seitdem auch wieder mehr
einfach über das thema sprechen
und deshalb möchte ich auch über das
thema sprechen und quasi gleich danach
als ich mich über das gesetz gefreut
habe habe ich das hier getan
diese eier produziert damit ich sie am
ende in den müll werfen
na super job vanessa und damit bin ich
natürlich nicht alleine in deutschland
werden laut einer studie von wwf 18
millionen tonnen lebensmittel im jahr
weggeschmissen 18 millionen tonnen
natürlich sind wir nicht ganz allein an
der zahl schuld aber 40 prozent gehen
von privathaushalten von diesen 18
millionen tonnen 40 prozent ist unsere
schuld und ihr müsst euch mal vorstellen
pro sekunde werden 3 113 kilo genießbare
lebensmittel weggeworfen
ob es jetzt von uns oder von den
supermärkten oder sonstwem irgendwelchen
restaurants oder was weiß ich werde
alles lebensmittel noch weg schmolz aber
3 113 kilogramm pro sekunde
es ist wenn dieses video hier fertig ist
ich will nicht wissen wie viele
kilogramm lebensmittel graf
weggeschmissen wurden aber woran liegt
es geht es uns einfach zu gut
in den siebziger jahren wurden noch 70
prozent des einkommens also was du von
deinem arbeitgeber gekriegt dass wurden
für lebensmittel ausgegeben und heute
sind es 14
was ist in dieser zeit passiert aber
jetzt mal ernsthaft ich wollte letztens
eine paprika kaufen die nicht in diesem
plastik verpackten dingen in diesen drei
dingen drin ist und eine einzelne
paprika hat irgendwas mit zwei euro
gekostet später bin ich dann zum
kühlfach gegangen wo hackfleisch drin
war und es hat einfach den gleichen
kilopreis gehabt wie die paprika ich
meine also ernsthaft jetzt ich blicke
nicht durch wir deutschen wollen einfach
viel weniger für lebensmittel ausgeben
anders zum beispiel die franzosen die
sind ein bisschen
gehobener und ja ich merke selbst dass
ich beim billigsten produkt zugreife
weil ich geld sparen möchte ich
entschuldige ist damit dass ich ja nicht
so viel geld habe aber ich denke dass es
eher eine ausrede als entschuldigung und
so geht es wohl viele discounter
begründen ihre preise damit dass es so
einen harten konkurrenzkampf auf dem
lebensmittelmarkt gibt gut aber das
macht bild teufelkreis noch schlimmer
und irgendwann muss jemand meine
ausbrechen und ich glaube die
supermärkte werden es nicht tun
deshalb sind wir auch mal an der reihe
aber wen wundert's 2014 wohnen in
deutschland 54 millionen schweine
geschlachtet 54 millionen das sind 18
millionen schweine mehr als noch vor 20
jahren
diese zeit kann man sich gar nicht
vorstellen und bei den einsatz auch
nicht besser aus
25 millionen eier mehr als noch im jahr
und ich meine das sind wir so verwöhnt
dass wir alles fließband artig in massen
vor uns haben wollen dass wir die größte
auswahl haben und den niedrigsten preis
bezahlen ganz ehrlich nein ich mag keine
bratwurst
so und jetzt kann sich jeder zurück
legen und sagen mama kauft man essen ein
also am liegt's nicht oder ich werfe so
selten was weg also meine schule ist das
alles nicht ich habe selbst gemacht aber
damit sollte mich jetzt schluss sein ich
mit wenigstens probieren und nun fragt
ihr euch um große vanessa was ist die
lösung dazu eine kleine geschichte ich
war letztens auf einer studentenparty im
pos kaum essen gab
irgendwann hat mir meine freundin
erzählt oder buht sharing man kommt
gleich und ich dachte er ich kannte
dieses foto sharing gar nicht bis ein
partygast mit einer riesigen kiste durch
die tür kam in dem croissants baguettes
und alles mögliche was man beim bäcker
kaufen kann drin war auf dem tisch
stellte und meinte bedient euch
er hat sich auf dieser phishing seite
angemeldet und hat geschaut welcher
becker gerade seine
lebensmittel loswerden möchte weil er
sie nicht wegschmeißen will dann kann
man mit so einer riesigen kiste an essen
an leckerem essen an
was eigentlich für den müll bestimmt war
wenn die vielleicht noch mehr über
dieses food sharing wissen wollt dann
packe ich euch mal ein paar links in die
video beschreibung und wer weiß
vielleicht seid ihr der nächste hoop
scheffer
ich glaube einfach dass wenn jeder sein
verhalten analysieren würde und man
wirklich schauen würde was kaufe ich ein
was schmeiße ich weg wie gehe ich mit
lebensmittel um das würde schon guten
anfang machen wir dürfen einfach nicht
darauf warten dass es so ein gesetz wie
in frankreich auch bei uns geben wird
wenn jetzt mehr zu dem thema wissen
wollt dann würde ich euch die doku face
to face ans herz legen denn die ist
wirklich gut und ihr wisst niemanden
findet ich will euch mit diesem video
nicht sagen dass sie alle schlecht seit
und vor allem nicht dass ich ein gutes
vorbild bin einmal darüber nachdenken
reicht mir schon aus und man muss sich
darüber im klaren sein dass hunger noch
überall auf der welt präsent ist und
vielleicht würde uns ein schlechtes
gewissen mal ganz gut tun
das war es auch schon von mir ich
wünsche euch eine schöne woche lasst uns
alle auf unser verhalten achten und dann
sage ich nur noch guten appetit